翻訳: Kayoko Shiomi
校正: Riaki Poništ
国境なき医師団は
中立の立場で
医療の届いていない場所に
公平に 平等に
医療を提供する団体です
日本にいると
その 医療が届いていないという状況は
なかなか想像が
つきにくいかもしれませんが
日本という小さな国から
一歩海を越えてみた時に
緊急的に医療が必要にもかかわらず
医療へのアクセスがない人々がたくさんいる
という現実があるんですね
その 医療が届いていないという
その理由には
例えば その地域に
お医者さんや病院が少なかったり
また お医者さんや病院はあるのだけれど
差別だったり 迫害を受けていて
人々の医療へのアクセスが
絶たれてしまっているような状況だったり
また 医療へのアクセスはあるのだけれど
治療法の分からないような病気が蔓延して
困っているような状況など 様々です
また そのような背景には
自然災害の発生
それから感染症の蔓延
難民生活 貧困などがあり
紛争もその一つにあげられます
私は日本とオーストラリアで
10年以上の看護師の経験を
積んできました
一口に看護師といっても
働く分野は様々です
小児科 内科 婦人科
救急 外来
たくさんある中で
私は外科や手術室での経験を
多く積んできました
国境なき医師団は
私の経験が活かせる場所
怪我をして手術が必要な患者さんが
多く運ばれる場所
つまり 紛争地に派遣される事が
多くなりました
そんな私は
2010年に参加して以来
イエメンやイラク シリア
南スーダン パレスチナなど
数多くの紛争地で活動してきました
私が国境なき医師団に出会ったのは
７歳の頃でした
医療に人種や国籍
政治的な信条だったり
また 信仰する宗教
それらの隔たりを乗り越えて
平等に医療を提供する人々がいると知り
幼いながらにも
心から尊敬と憧れの念を抱きました
その後 私は看護師という
素晴らしい職業に出会うことができ
私の人生の軸というのは看護師—
看護師が 私の人生の
軸となっていきました
100万人以上の看護師を
抱える日本では
私一人が抜けたとしても
医療体制が崩壊するなどということは
考えられません
ところが 国境なき医師団が
入るような現場では
看護師１人が抜けることで
医療が回らなくなってしまう
そんなような場所がたくさんあるのだ
ということを知りました
１人の医者 １人の看護師の価値は
とても高まり
今まで医療が届いていなかった場所に
医療を届けるという喜びを
見出す事ができました
ところが 紛争地の派遣を重ねるうちに
そのような喜びは 次第に
憤りだったり 怒り 挫折や
無力感へと繋がっていきました
紛争地では 空爆や砲弾
銃弾 地雷など
紛争の暴力によって
人々が血を流して運ばれてきます
中には手や足がもぎれそうな状態だったり
また 爆発時に吹き飛んだ色々な破片物が
体中に突き刺さっているような
状態だったり
そして 運ばれてくる時には
もうすでに亡くなっている方もいます
大の大人から お年寄り
妊婦さんや 乳飲み子だって
血を流して運ばれてきます
ある夜のことです
８人の子供たちが
一気に運ばれてきました
銃弾や空爆から身を守るために
昼間は家の中に
閉じこもっていた子たちが
夜になり音が止んで
外に出て遊び始めたそうです
その時に 道端で転がっていた
面白そうなもの 珍しいものを発見して
みんなで突いたり蹴ったりして
遊んでいたそうです
ところが それは時限爆弾で
そこにいた子供たち全員の
手や足を吹き飛ばしました
私たち外科チームは 朝まで
８人の子供たちの
切断手術に追われました
この写真は
自分たちにはもう手や足がないのだ
という現実を突きつけられる前の
まだ麻酔から目が覚めていない時の写真です
この50代の女性は 空爆で
旦那さんと ４人の子供
そして 自分の片足を失くしました
麻酔から目を覚ました彼女が
私の顔を見て
「死なせて」と言いました
仕事中は 泣かないようにしていますが
この時は 彼女の手を握りながら
泣いてしまいました
この女の子が
空爆の被害に遭った１人として
集団で運ばれてきた時に
家族らしき人物は
見当たりませんでした
名前も年齢も分からないまま収容し
緊急的に手術を行って
命を助けることはできましたが
混迷する紛争地で
身元の分からない彼女の運命は
そもそも紛争地では
医療活動を行うということが
簡単ではありません
本当に医療を必要としている人々の元に
辿りつくことが困難です
それは 私たちの身の安全をも
確保しなければならないからです
それに 私たちがいくら中立の立場で
医療を施そうとも
そこには障害も立ちはだかります
ここ近年では 医療施設が空爆をされる
という事件も多発しています
たった１つの命令
たった１つのボタンによって
落とされる空爆の空の下で
罪のない人々が 恐怖にさらされ
血を流し 泣き叫んでいます
誰もが平等に与えられるはずの医療でさえ
自由に施せない紛争地で
全く戦争に加担をしていない人々の命を
救っても 救っても
そして 次にまた
血だらけの人が運ばれてくる
そのような日常を繰り返すうちに
私は この戦争は止めなくてはいけないんだ
と思うようになりました
ところが 私が行っている
看護活動というのは
戦争を止めるための根本的な活動に
繋がっていない
そのことに大きなジレンマを
抱くようになってしまいました
そこで 私は
人生の軸としていた看護師をやめ
夢だった 国境なき医師団を去り
ジャーナリストになろうという
大きな決断を下しました
自分が目撃しているこの現状を
国際社会に訴えて
戦争を止めるための動きに
繋げようと思ったのです
ただ 私には
ジャーナリストになるという手段が
全く分かりませんでした
そこで 実際のジャーナリストの人々に
相談をしてみました
その結果
「ジャーナリストになったからといって
戦争は止められないよ」
「その仕事は自分たちが頑張っている
あなたは看護師でしょう
だったら 今すぐ現場に戻って
人々の命を救い続けなさい」
そのようなことを言われ
全く相手にしてもらえませんでした
途方に暮れてしまった私ですが
でも そんな中でも
また紛争地派遣の依頼が来ました
そして この時の紛争地で出会った
17歳の女の子が
その後の私の看護師人生への
大きなきっかけを与えてくれたのです
この女の子は
戦争が始まる前までは
普通に高校に通っていた女の子でした
ところが 空爆に遭い
彼女の足がめちゃめちゃに損傷し
ふさぎこんでいました
そんな彼女を気にかけ
私は手術室以外でも 手を握り
話し掛け続けていました
全く反応はなく
彼女は１人ベッドの上で
傷の痛み そして心の痛みと
戦っていたのです
そんな日々を過ごすうちに
私にも帰国をしなくてはならない
日がやってきました
そこで彼女に「一緒に写真を撮ろうよ」
と話し掛けました
「私はもう帰国をしてしまうけれど
あなたのことを私は忘れたくはない
あなたの顔をずっと見ていたいから
だから一緒に写真を撮ろう」
そのように伝えました
そして ついに彼女が笑ったのです
こんなに素敵な写真が撮れました
私は思わず彼女を抱きしめました
そして 何よりも
この時に気づいたこと
それは 私は看護師だから
この子の笑顔を見ることができた
看護師だから この子の手を握り
話しかけ だから見れた
ジャーナリストの仕事も大変尊いです
でも やっぱり私は看護師なのだ
心の声に従い選んだ
看護師という職業の素晴らしさに
改めて気づいた瞬間だったのです
紛争地において理想の医療など
ありえないと思っていました
物資も薬剤も人材にも限りがあり
なかなか思うように
医療活動が進まない
その中で 志さえも踏みにじられてしまう
そのように思っていました
医療で 戦争は止まらない
それも本当にその通りです
では その極限下で
私たちに求められることは何だろう
私たちができることは何だろう
それは その時にできる
最善の医療を提供すること
その中で 手を握るとか
話しかけるとか
それだけでも良いのかもしれません
手を握るということは
その人を気に掛けること
その人に寄り添うということです
恐怖や 絶望 憎しみ
悲しみが交錯する中で
誰かがそばにいて手を握る
そのことだけでも
大きな力になっているかもしれない
と気づきました
私は先ほどの女の子の笑顔を
引き出すことができました
これって 私たちの日常にも
通用することだとは思いませんか
困っていたり 悩んでいたり
何かしらの辛さを
抱えている人というのは
なにも紛争地のような極限下に
いる人たちだけとは限らないはずです
不安だと言っている人に
安定剤を渡すよりも
眠れないと言っている人に
ただ 睡眠薬を渡すよりも
痛いと言っている人に
痛み止めを与えるよりも
そばにいて手を握る
このことだけでも
不安が軽減されたり 痛みや辛さが
減ったりするかもしれません
寄り沿うということを
もう一度見直して
日本の社会にも
取り入れていきませんか
もしあなたの隣に
困っている人がいたら
是非 その人の手を握ってあげて下さい
ありがとうございました
(拍手）